everybody it's Charlie's they revealed
the official plot synopsis for
spider-man far from home and it
confirmed some big things that the
actors were saying during their
comic-con panel last week so we got to
break it down we're doing a new round of
that IMAX ticket giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave your favorite spider-man moment on
the video the official plot synopsis
reads Peter Parker and his friends go on
summer holidays to Europe however the
friends will hardly be able to rest
Peter will have to agree to help Nick
Fury uncover the mystery of creatures
that cause natural disasters and
destruction throughout the continent so
these are the elementals that Jake
Gyllenhaal Tom Holland and Jacob Babylon
were talking about during their
comic-con panel here's a quick clip of
that to defeat all these elemental
monsters there are these threats to the
worlds the elementals elemental
creatures in there and mysterious um you
know who who knows about them and wants
to make sure that the world is safe from
them and and Nick Fury asked him to come
on and help because he's the only one
who really sort of understands them in a
way and I did a video about that this
last weekend a lot of people were like
oh they're probably lying to us about
Mysterio being a hero in these
elementals they're not real well I think
you're half right there I definitely
think the elementals are not real
because we're talking about Mysterio
here but the actors go on and on about
how Mysterio is gonna be a good guy in
this one there was even a funny
behind-the-scenes clip that Tom Holland
posted on his Instagram of him and Jake
Gyllenhaal just having fun and you can
see him in the background pretending to
be spider-man it's hilarious everyone
thank you so much to everyone in Brazil
it's been a fantastic day the whole
spider-man concert so that's like a
4-dimensional joke yeah it's funny to
see him pretending to be spider-man but
I told the story a little while ago
about how he almost became spider-man
during the Tobey Maguire era but it also
plays into the idea of what Mysterio is
doing during spider-man far from home
he's trying to be a hero or make himself
look like a hero just like spider-man in
the Avengers he did this movie a little
while ago called Nightcrawler where he
has this crazy idea in his head that
he's gonna be a big star he's gonna be
famous and he just totally twisted in
the way he goes about doing that his
morality is completely upside-down he
has no scruples he'll do anything in
fight anyway to justify it in his head
in his pursuit of Fame so he winds up
doing all this really messed up stuff
people end up dying all around him but
because he's psychotic he believes that
this is all awesome like oh wow this is
so great it's just this totally way
bizarre of thinking about yourself that
sounds exactly like what's happening
with Mysterio during this film like I
want to be a hero I don't know quite how
to do that
but I'm really good with technology and
illusions so I'm gonna use that to try
and make myself look like a hero even
though it does sound like they're
changing the comics quite a bit all this
is based and inspired by spider-man
Mysterio comics in the past is the same
thing that they did with the vulture
during spider-man homecoming so a lot of
the things the actors have been saying
in the official plot description of
spider-man far from home sounds like a
little bit of Mysterio's first official
battle with spider-man an amazing
spider-man number 13 during that first
big official battle Mysterio dresses up
like spider-man and fakes it to make it
look like spider-man has been robbing a
bunch of museums till spider-man is able
to stop him and trick him into revealing
himself on live camera so it's Mysterio
tried to make himself look like a hero
by using his illusions to throw other
people under the bus Jake Gyllenhaal has
not given his full official MCU
backstory yet so we don't know exactly
what his original motivation is but what
it sounds like is going on is that he's
sort of a twisted version of spider-man
somebody who grows up idolizing the
Avengers in spider-man sees how famous
they are the praise that they get from
everyone wants that for himself but
because I mean he's a classic spider-man
villain has some fundamental flaw within
him that prevents him from being a real
hero but he has all these crazy skills
can make his own technology so being
psychotic like a lot of great spider-man
villains justifies this carefully
orchestrated plan to create a bunch of
threats that he is then able to take
down because he's able to control them
so he's trying to make himself look like
a superhero but obviously spider-man is
on the case and will probably find out
what's going on and then it turns into
more of a traditional spy
man versus Mysterio battle but
everything they've been saying about
Mysterio being a hero
teaming up with spider-man to save the
world all this great energy like it
seems like their buddies sitting on
stage together talking about the movie
seems like it's from the first twenty to
thirty minutes of the movie in the
movies like two plus hours so at some
point Spiderman will have to find out
that things aren't quite right and
follow the trail of evidence back to
Mysterio but like I said comic-book
changes remember spider-man homecoming
is a good benchmark for how they're
changing comic book Mysterio so comic
book Adrian Toomes was betrayed by his
business partner ended up losing his job
and was forced into a life of crime MCU
vulture lost his job because of Iron Man
so he turned to a life of crime few big
fundamental changes because Iron Man
wasn't part of that original story but
the basic comic-book plot is still there
so using that as a benchmark for MCU
Mysterio Quentin Beck in the comics
wanted to be a big star wanted people to
love him but he just couldn't quite cut
it in Hollywood the traditional way but
he was an amazing special-effects wizard
it was smart enough to be able to create
his own technology himself so he figured
he could use that to become a super
villain and gain notoriety that way
become famous but in a very twisted
psychotic way so I did a trailer
breakdown a little while ago this past
weekend I'll link that video at the end
of this based on that footage that we
saw and based on what jake gyllenhaal
has told us early timeline theory of the
movie MCU Quentin Beck idealizes the
Avengers in spider-man sees the love and
admiration they get from heroes during
events of the previous Avengers movies
and desperately wants that for himself
to like I want to be a hero I want
everyone to love me just like them but
he just doesn't have quite what it takes
to make it as an Avenger like he's a
villain so something has to be wrong
with him on a fundamental level but he's
really smart he's a tech wizard and he
can create his own illusions and
technology to make himself look like a
superhero so people will love him and
value him just as much as he feels like
they value the Avengers so maybe he
creates these elemental threats through
his illusion technology maybe with a
little bit of help from other sinister
six characters there's more speculation
but there are a bunch of other
characters in the film that are
unaccounted for in any of the trailer
footage or in any of the descriptions
that we've gotten
Pharr so what would be weird if Mysterio
is able to create these giant elemental
properties the seemingly destroy all
these different cities all by himself it
seems like he has a little bit of help
on the DL so in the trailer footage
these different elementals pop up in
London Prague Venice
all over the cities the Spider Man
travels to in the film and that's when
Mysterio comes to Nick Fury and says
that he's the only person that can take
them down because he probably totally
made them and can manipulate them
himself so he can orchestrate a fake
battle with one of them take them down
and make himself look like a total
badass like he earned a big victory over
one of them and show Nick Fury see I'm
the only person that can handle this so
when Jake Gyllenhaal says that Nick Fury
hires him to take down these elementals
that's probably how their relationship
starts but because Nick Fury is nobody's
fool he probably doesn't totally buy it
and if you guys were confused about the
Nick Fury Maria Hill Shield situation of
it all
shield is coming back during Avengers 4
so as of the end of Avengers 4 beginning
of spider-man far from home shield is
back to its old self like what you saw
during the original Avengers movie
during age of Ultron like yeah there was
all that Winter Soldier stuff but the
same basic framework is there it just
seems like they're going to reform
shield during the course of Avengers 4
but the Nick Fury trailer footage that
we saw didn't make it real clear if it
was before they found out about
Mysterio's plan when he first comes to
meet spider-man or if it's after that
there was a scene of him coming to meet
spider-man for the first time like he
came to meet Iron Man like he just shows
up he darts Ned leads in the neck and
knocks him out in their hotel room so
that he can have a private conversation
with Peter Parker he says so I finally
get to meet the spider-man then
obviously tasks him with trying to take
down these elementals because spider-man
it all turns tries to avoid doing
superhero stuff on vacation but because
he's spider-man he's a hero he wants to
help people and he sees all these
disasters happening they did hype up the
stealth suit they don't say exactly when
during the movie he gets that but we
know that he has it during the prog bite
and because Tom Holland says that I
won't tell you what it's used for like
he wouldn't tell us the exact scenes
that he was using it in it sounds like
it might be after he figures out what
Mysterio is doing and he uses it as a
form of stealth so that Mysterio won't
see him
coming and he can catch him in the act
of trying to create one of his illusions
there were trailer scenes with Mysterio
fighting the big elementals but there
wasn't anything to let you know that he
was going to be fighting spider-man like
all the footage in the trailer supported
what the actors were saying like
Mysterio is gonna be a hero in this one
but like I said it sounds like the
footage in the trailer just like the
Avengers 4 trailer is all from just the
first 20 to 30 minutes of the movie Jake
Gyllenhaal was also hyping up to the
fishbowl in his comic book suit about
how it has a bunch of secrets they said
that it lights up a lot on set
practically obviously they're gonna tune
that up and special effects in
post-production later on so it'll look
really fantastic his suit is probably
just one big sophisticated projector
system for projecting his illusions so
let me know in the comments classic
comic book Mysterio is very duplicitous
and will do anything to make himself
look like a hero do you think that
that's what's going on with this you
know quote-unquote fake Mysterio plot to
make himself look like a hero in
spider-man far from home and for those
of you asking about the trailer dropping
online that's supposed to be sometime in
the next two weeks according to recent
reports but nobody has given an official
date yet whenever it does happen I will
totally make a video for it
venom is coming out on digital tomorrow
so there'll be a bunch of deleted scenes
and post-credit scenes I'll do videos
for that stuff in spider-man into the
spider verse is hitting theaters this
week be sure to go see it because I'll
be doing Easter egg videos and
post-credit scenes and all that stuff
later this week while you wait for
everything click here to rewatch that
spider-man far from home trailer
breakdown in that big Comic Con panel
and click here to rewatch the Avengers 4
trailer a billion more times thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight